it's time for the launch in chrono scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Kranz cope from the CBS television
user Larry lesser and Winston brunette
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable Kenneth peak heating
representative from New York
representative Keating you were a
veteran of both world wars I'd like to
ask you something about a situation
which exists today do you think the time
has now come for the government to frame
new defense policies in the light of the
hydrogen bomb well Larry I'm no expert
even though I have had some military
experience my feeling is that we mustn't
get into hysteria over some new
development we have known of the
potentiality increasingly dangerous
potentialities of these atomic weapons
and we're making plans to meet those
threats and I have the feeling that we
have in the White House today a man who
is the best able to cope with that
problem of anyone in the world that I
can think of and I am perfectly contempt
to leave the decision as to what changes
what shifts in our defense policy should
be made to him and his advisors
representative Keating is a member of
the Judiciary Committee you regard the
threat to the security of this country
is coming primarily from the outside or
is it primarily an internal threat as
some congressmen have said well it's
both in my opinion the
a communist conspiracy is international
there is certainly a threat from the
outside and there is great evidence that
there are those in our own country among
our own people who would seek to destroy
us I can't understand it but we're bound
to admit that that exists I don't know
which is the greater we must take steps
to deal with both of those problems in
my judgment wherever senator Keating and
regarding the internal threat what about
the Attorney General's request for a
wiretapping bill are you in favor of
that I am in favor of it i'm the author
of a bill which has been favorably
reported by the Judiciary Committee and
is now before the house for action that
bill permits the use in evidence of in
criminal trials involving treason
espionage sabotage sedition seditious
conspiracy in violation of the atomic
energy act of evidence which has been
obtained by intercepting communications
sometimes called wiretapping well
representative you think that the as a
high-ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee that the Attorney General
should have the power to order wiretaps
or should they be brought about as a
court order and only upon a court order
well that is a subject upon which many
very reasonable and sensible and good
people differ I originally felt that it
was desirable to go to the court and
obtain a court order in fact I
introduced a bill which provided for
that before permitting the use of the
evidence in court now I became convinced
that it should be done by the Attorney
General I'll be glad to tell you why I
became convinced to that it must be
remembered that this evidence is legally
obtained it exists now this what we're
talking about is whether or not it can
be used in evidence in court
in in prosecutions for offenses
involving our national security now
there are there there's a certain amount
of delay going to ensue from going to a
court there aren't that many more people
that are going to find out about it and
then the thing that clinched it with me
was this he when in conferences with the
Attorney General and mr. Hoover the
director of the FBI I was told that
under orders of the Attorney General the
FBI had already intercepted
communications in cases where there was
evidence which would lead to which could
be used in court against people against
enemies of our country which they have
already collected but are barred from
using under existing statutes now Givens
be an ex post facto law they know if we
required a court order in such cases
they couldn't use that evidence because
it wasn't obtained by court order there
was nothing requiring them to get it and
it is not ex post facto for this reason
that phrase applies to creating a new
crime later now this is not the creation
of a new client crime it's simply
permitting the use in evidence of
evidence already obtained it is not
there is possibility that we might be
giving too much power to the police
authorities of the country by giving the
Attorney General the sole right to the
other one general is is an enforcement
officer and he's the officer charged
with the responsibility of enforcing the
criminal laws of our country and of
course our most probably our most
important criminal laws in the nation
federal laws are those relating to our
internal security such as treason and I
think that he is the one peculiarly able
to decide whether it is an appropriate
case for the information to be obtained
in this way and he it may it centralizes
responsibility in him so that if he does
not if he acts gets out of line and does
not act in accordance with the
proprieties the Congress has one man
upon whom they can pin the
responsibility instead of having it
diffused among two or three hundred
federal judges throughout the country
sir to take up another of your personal
proposals your bills which you have
brought forward what is the status now
of your bill for granting immunity from
prosecution to persons who otherwise
might plead the fifth Amendment against
self-incrimination well that is as you
say another administration measure along
with the anti trader or wiretap bill now
in this bill would permit the Attorney
General to grant immunity from
prosecution in in certain cases if he
felt the national interest required it
and then compel those witnesses to
testify that bill is now in committee
and a hearing is expected very shortly
honor that I am hopeful that it will be
reported favorably very soon by the
Judiciary Committee I want to call your
attention to this that there were in the
nineteen fifty three in just the
congressional committees of Congress
three 305 people who refuse to answer
whether or not they were communists or
whether or not they'd committed
espionage your questions of that kind
now the people are upset throughout this
country with with that they they we of
course want to maintain our
constitutional safeguards there are very
prominent jurists who think that perhaps
the reason for the Fifth Amendment may
have gone by now that it was established
first in are at a time tuned in an
effort to avoid people being forced to
confess by torture but and that that
doesn't exist now I don't agree with a
man should retain it but I do think that
we've got to meet this situation this
challenge to our security and posed by
these people and in certain cases
require them to answer but grant them
immunity from prosecution Arizona
kidding I was going to say mask what
would you do to people who are granted
immunity from prosecution who refuse to
tell if they are members of the
Communist Party refuse to tell who are
the members of their cells and
to them well that's no ground for under
their Supreme Court decisions on that
one cannot refuse to answer on the
ground that it may incriminate someone
else that is not a valid ground under
the Fifth Amendment for refusing in the
Supreme Court is so held the only person
who can refuse to answer and not be
abusing the Fifth Amendment is one who
believes sincerely in his own heart that
his answer if truthful would tend to
incriminate sir I'd like to ask you this
are there any legal precedents in our
state's in any of our states for
granting to an attorney general some of
the special powers that would be granted
oh yes in 32 of our 48 states for
instance permit the use of evidence
intercepted by wiretapping courts and
the immunity on the authorization of the
no no I think in most of those cases it
and great many of them it does require
court order that's that's true but on
the immunity question there I think
nearly every state prosecuting officer
has that power now to grant immunity
from prosecution and the federal
jurisdiction they don't have it at all
and my bill would extend it not only to
congressional committees but also to
courts and before grand juries whoever
senator Keating as a as one of the real
experts on our judiciary of this country
like to ask you if you believe that in
these special investigation of the
McCarthy subcommittee whether you think
senators McCarthy should have the right
to cross-examine witnesses on that
hearing although he has a part in the
case well in the code of fair play that
I've drawn up and have introduced in the
house as a bill and it provided for
everyone to have anyone whose name was
brought into a hearing in a way that he
thought injured him to have the right of
cross-examination for not to exceed one
hour and I would believe that anyone
should have that right Senator McCarthy
or anybody on the other side or anyone
else however i must say that in the
committee of which i was the chairman
investigating the department of justice
I was not even able to sell my own
committee
that and what we adapted was a plan
whereby a person who felt his name had
been brought in improperly in the
hearing was permitted to send up
questions and propound them to the
committee to put to the witness I think
that Senator McCarthy or anyone else
they should all be treated on a parody
and everyone if he's to have the right
across examination of course the other
side should have that right well the
final question sir I'd like to ask you
if you can do it briefly whether you
think the Communist Party should be
outlawed in this country on a state or
federal level well there are bills in to
do that and I have felt always in the
past I have agreed with mr. Hoover the
head of the FBI that that was not the
right approach that that was apt to
drive them underground and that rather
the approach to bring them out and
require them to come out in the open and
to register upon which we passed
legislation is the better approach and
then if they don't register under that
law they go to jail but I believe that
that bill is coming up shortly for
hearings before my committee and I want
to entertain a certain amount of an open
mind until I've heard what is said on
that subject well thank you very much
represent of katie has been very
interesting to have you here tonight the
opinions expressed on the lawn team
Chronos cope were those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the lawn gene Cronus cope was Larry
lesser and Winston brunette our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
cannot be Keating representative from
New York